the family of a Wisconsin woman who died
after possibly drinking tainted alcohol
is now suing the Mexican resort that
served her Abby Connor drowned in a pool
at the Iberostar Hotel and Resort in
Riviera Maya after drinking while on
vacation with her family in January of
2017 her family alleges at the resort
new the alcohol they gave the 20 year
old was poisonous
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with new details
from this lawsuit Vlad good morning good
morning Abby Connors family says her
death was entirely avoidable at the
hands of the Ibero hotel and resort now
nearly two years later they've filed a
lawsuit asking for the resort to be held
responsible Abby Connor had only been at
Iberostar Paraiso del Mar for a few
hours in January 2017 when her family
says hotel staff served her and her
older brother Austin tainted alcohol at
a hotel pool soon after her family says
Abby was found by hotel staff floating
facedown while her brother was drowning
nearby in shallow water
Abby later died at a Florida Hospital
her brother survived according to the
new wrongful death lawsuit filed in
Florida and obtained by the Milwaukee
Journal Sentinel the resort knew that
alcoholic beverages being served were
tainted substandard poisonous and unfit
for human consumption
the family is now seeking damages in
excess of fifteen thousand dollars it's
been a nightmare terrific a few months
after Abby's death her mother Ginny
McGowan warned people about drinking in
Mexico be very very careful of what you
eat drink or you don't know what's
necessarily in a drink or food after
Connors death Mexican authorities raided
thirty-one establishments they seized
around 90 gallons of alcohol being kept
in unsanitary conditions in February the
general reports tests found around two
hundred and thirty-five gallons of a
different seized supply of alcohol
contained dangerous levels of methanol a
chemical commonly used in windshield
washer fluid they said I couldn't get
out of the pool and I wasn't even able
to stand up in the pool
Cathy Daley previously told CBS News she
believes she drank tainted alcohol while
staying at Annie barrows star hotel
in Mexico they said I was vomiting all
over the place
and they had to call the hotel doctor
and Daly does not appear to be alone the
Milwaukee Journal Sentinel says since
Abby's death it has received more than
200 reports from US tourists who had
similar experiences at luxury resorts in
Mexico we thought we you know were safe
in a five-star rated resort but it's
apparent that you're not ribeiro star
hotels and resorts told us in a
statement it does not comment on pending
or existing litigation the State
Department has previously warned
travelers to consume alcohol in
moderation in Mexico and immediately
seek medical attention if feeling sick
but of course if the alcohol is tainted
it's hard to know terrible
beware Thank You Vlad